bonsoir julie daubié oublier cette
semaine a été un baiser de plus oui vous
étiez posez vous la question avoir
commise et carmen non mais j'aurais pu
me la pole à poser mais c'est vrai que
dans ma famille on parle de ça plus
ouvertement je sais pas on s'était on se
l'est jamais vraiment posé mais on
aurait voilà j'ai pas un jour n'avait
dit commencer si on aime une fille ou un
garçon et les parents avec du boeuf
chypre faisait dadjé par les filles ou
par les garçons quelque chose d'assez
naturel mais je me suis jamais posé la
question j'ai tout de suite été attiré
par les garçons quand vous avez les
travaux et quand vous avez lu le
scénario
quelle a été votre première réaction
génial c'est la première fois qu'on
parle de l'homosexualité féminine comme
ça beaucoup plus d'ailleurs c'est les
femmes ont le rôle majeur quand même
dans ce film c'est tellement plus
qu'elle est d'habitude c'est toujours je
pas la cage aux folles où beaucoup dans
les films en films sur l'homosexualité
des garçons qui ont d'ailleurs toujours
ses traits les grandes folles et tout ça
c'est ou alors c'est des films très
sérieux beaucoup plus réaliste et là
c'est un mélange des deux messages
s'agit aussi des enfants un film
différent
alors on vous dit l'un des pères ce sera
johnny hallyday alors vous réagissez
comme ans parce que moi je suis la
génération ses idoles
comment vous vous êtes retrouvé enfin
comment vous ai fait un peu comme
aujourd'hui le trac
selon les mains moites et puis après
c'était mon père quand voilà c'était le
comédien et on était c'est un bonheur un
bonheur
mais c'est vrai que je n'étais que quand
nous allons ce canton non mais quand on
l'a fait ces films surtout bon je pense
que ça se voit sur fion c'est vraiment
beaucoup marré quoi ouais pendant le
tournage
selon le tournage avait quand même même
mais mort hors tournage veut dire enfin
sur le fond plutôt que c'était un
bonheur de se retrouver tous ensemble
mais vous êtes complètement à contre
emploi comme là dedans me souhaiter un
symbole de virilité
je suis content que stéphane mais
proposé ce rôle parce que moi je vous
les jouets les absolument un rôle à
contre emploi
je voulais pas faire un retour au cinéma
j'ai fait pas mal de films un retour au
cinéma être employé comme j'ai été
employé c'est-à-dire au t1 les proches
qu'est ce que les gens pensent que je
suis en réalité dans la vie c'est à dire
autre jeune ailier tout simplement pour
être crédible quand on a un nom connu
dans un autre métier
quoique très proche chanteur et comédien
à ses très proches mais quand même
chanteur c'est difficile sur un écran
concours d'être crédible quand on a un
autre personnage à jouer donc la seule
façon d'être crédible c'est de faire
quelque chose de complètement différent
de faire un rôle à contre emploi
enfin vous êtes le père peut-être le
plus compréhensif le plus sympa que dans
tout ça et pourtant le plus macho
puisque je suis comme avaya d'or à peu
sur le retour et et mais comme j'aime
profondément ma fille je sais que j'aime
profondément et que je cherche à la
comprendre jeu disons que la tolérance
bien avec ça il est ce qu'on a voulu je
pense que stéphane surtout notre metteur
en scène a voulu montrer dans ce film
c'est là c'est un film sur l'amour et la
tolérance
mais honnêtement il ya 20 ans il ya
trente ans n'aurait jamais pu faire ce
genre de film la tolérance à engraisser
attendant lens il y avait les tabous il
y avait tabou qui se sont quand même
effondré depuis depuis 20 ans 30 ans
c'est vrai que on n'aurait jamais pu
faire un film sur l'homosexualité homme
ou femme est comme ça même mais mal en
rigolant comme aujourd'hui vous allez
progresser à thèmes sérieux à les
traiter encore vu des corps mais vous
même personnellement l'homme vous avez
progressé dans la tolérance à l'égard
d'une sexualité différent j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui sont en mousse femmes qui
sont membres sexuelle moi ça ne me
dérange pas parce que
ce sont des gens les plus les gens est
plus touchant et en général les gens les
plus ce sont les gens qui sont les plus
sincères julie gayet quelle est la leçon
vous tiré de ses personnages vous êtes
plusieurs femmes à assumer votre
sexualité à le dire ouvertement et à le
dire dans une vraie joie comme un
brouillon il ya un petit peu de larmes
et d'une vraie joie là si on allait en
tout cas de l'assumer mais en fait pas
vraiment je pense que c'est ça reste et
eva c'est quand même une dragueuse ici
elle drague comme ça parce qu'il doit y
avoir quelque chose d'un peu et je pense
que c'est ça le dire à ses parents est
vraiment assumer ça c'était un truc à
moi je pense que c'est important et
c'est pas facile et évident donc en fait
c'est elle et touchant pour moi je sais
ce que j'aime mon souci c'est vrai c'est
une comédie vraiment et en même temps on
sent que voilà c'est pas facile comme ce
qui est important de jeu qui est
important c'est que pour un acteur de
jouer un rôle d'homosexuel que soient
vos femmes quand on l'est pas surtout
c'est de jouer et c'est pas jouer la
folle quoi le malware traditionnels
comme il ya comme on voit des fois des
clichés dans des films qui sont même à
la limite ça frise le ridicule
c'est ça qui est important comme on
m'aime un homosexuel un vrai de jouer un
rôle
dans l'âme qu'il n'y ait pas qu'il n'est
pas du tout homosexuel c'est ça d'être
avec quelqu'un d'autre mais rj deuxième
vous êtes partie parfaite naturel quand
vous lui annoncer il est là merci pour
tout ce qui m'arrive
ainsi pour ce film qui sort donc
aujourd'hui sur les écrans je vais
revenir plus sérieusement parce que je
pense que vous êtes vous aussi touchée
par la mort de michel brettés szczesny
c'était quelqu'un que vous estimez vous
pouvez bien sûr oui je ne connaissais
pas personnellement
malheureusement mais tout ce que je peux
dire c'est que dans le jazz et surtout
dans la musique c'était un très grand
musicien et il va nous manquer à tous
merci beaucoup